[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRESENTER: Good morning.
The announcement
of the Nobel Prize
going to our friend
and colleague Wolfgang
Ketterle and his
colleagues comes
like a bright ray of light into
a very dark period for MIT,
and for our nation and world.
This is really a
wonderful day for Wolfgang
and his colleagues, it's
a wonderful day for MIT,
and it certainly is a wonderful
day for physics and science
in general.
We're absolutely delighted.
I would also like to say
that this award reminds us
once again of how
incredibly important
it is for our
nation's universities
to keep their doors
and their campuses
open to those wonderful people
who come to the United States
from many other nations
around the world
to build the tremendous
intellectual and human
community that we have.
But you're not here
today to hear from me,
you're here today to hear
from our colleague, Wolfgang
Ketterle, who's joined by
professors Dave Pritchard, Dan
Kleppner, and Tom Greytak.
As you will hear, this has
been a tremendous team effort,
and has a long
history here at MIT
that has led up to this
wonderful day for Wolfgang.
So let me introduce the man
of the hour, our colleague,
Professor Wolfgang Ketterle.
[APPLAUSE]
[CHEERING]
KETTERLE: Thank
you all for coming.
It's an overwhelming
experience, you know?
There are many emotions.
You're overjoyed, you are
thrilled, you are scared,
it's surreal.
It's only slowly that I
think reality sinks in.
I mean, this is
something really big,
and it's a big distinction.
And it's wonderful
to celebrate it,
and it's also wonderful
that here in this room
there are people who have
greatly contributed to that,
either my collaborators
or people who
have mentoring my career and
have greatly supported me.
So it's a great
moment for MIT, it's
a great moment for
atomic physics,
it's a great moment
for all of us.
And I'm really grateful and
proud for many, many people.
AUDIENCE: Could you say
something about your colleagues
at Colorado?
KETTERLE: Yes.
This prize is shared with
Eric Cornell and Carl Wieman
at the University of Colorado.
And we know each other very
well, and since the early '90s
we have been really racing
towards colder temperatures
and hunting for this
new form of matter.
It has been the best
competition of my life.
And it's just great to see that
there is no loser, no winner.
I mean, we have both
shared the excitement
and the thrill of a
new field, and we all
got [INAUDIBLE] cognition.
So they have been
wonderful colleagues,
and they have done
excellent and great work.
And it's been exciting.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] history
represented by your colleagues?
KETTERLE: Yeah, actually the
field of ultra-cold atoms
has a long history.
And a lot of pioneering
work was done here at MIT.
It started in the late 1970s
with Tom Greytak and Dan
Kleppner pursuing Bose-Einstein
condensation atomic hydrogen.
And it seemed that atomic
hydrogen was really
just unique, and no other atom
would be suitable for that.
But then came other
people, among them
Dave Pritchard, who
pioneered laser cooling.
And that opened a
new perspective.
And eventually,
it was the merger
of both fields which led
to the big breakthrough.
And I really feel privileged
that, when I joined MIT
in the early '90s, that I
was privileged to complete
this work and accomplish
the observation
of Bose-Einstein condensation.
But MIT has been really special.
It's a 20-year-long
tradition of atomic physics
in pursuit of
Bose-Einstein condensation
which came to fruition.
And it's sometimes embarrassing
to see that I get recognized,
but I think it's a
recognition for all of us.
And I'm proud to be part of MIT.
AUDIENCE: One other thing.
Could you talk just a
bit about explaining
Bose-Einstein condensate to
those of us who [INAUDIBLE]??
KETTERLE: OK.
[LAUGHTER]
So, well, Bose-Einstein
condensation
is a new form of matter.
It's a special form
of matter which
forms at the lowest
temperatures ever achieved.
But just to address
you as lay people,
you may wonder why can
get physicists so excited
about a little puff
of gas in millimeter
or sub-millimeter-sized
cloud of almost nothing?
But we get excited because
it has special properties.
The sample consists
of millions of atoms,
and they all
oscillate in lockstep.
They sing in unison.
It's a very special
form of matter, which
has very special properties.
And by discovering and
studying this form of matter,
we learn more about nature.
And I think this is the first
[INAUDIBLE] for physicists
if you discover a
new form of matter,
if you explore new properties.
You have a deep look into
the beauty of nature.
And this is exciting.
Now, this form of matter,
because it is so special,
has widespread implications.
And some of them may
be in the applied area.
So there is speculation
that this form of matter
may find uses for
precision measurements,
for better atomic clocks,
for nanotechnology, maybe
even for a novel form
of quantum computation.
But this is the job of my
team and the other groups
worldwide to explore that and
figure out if that is possible.
But it is typical for
fundamental research
that there is something
which has a new quality,
and then there are
numerous possibilities
which can be explored.
Maybe to give you
an analogy, what
has been accomplished with
Bose-Einstein condensation
is for atoms for
material particles
the same step which was
taken for light when
the laser was invented.
You all know the difference
between a light bulb
and a laser beam.
Until the discovery in '95
in atomic physics with atoms,
we were in the era
of light bulbs.
We only had atomic light
bulbs, atoms randomly moving.
But all of a sudden, with
a breakthrough in '95,
we have now streams
of atoms which
have exactly the same
properties as a laser.
All atoms move in lockstep,
highly directional
beams of atoms.
So in some sense, we
have repeated something
with atoms what was accomplished
with the optical laser some 30
years earlier.
And I think it's fair to say
that those developments have
revolutionized atomic physics.
It has changed the way how
atomic physics is done now.
MODERATOR: Questions?
AUDIENCE: As a physicist,
is it every physicist's goal
to win the Nobel like it
would be to win the Super
Bowl for a football player?
[LAUGHTER]
KETTERLE: No, definitely not.
We do physics for
the excitement,
we do physics for
just being creative.
And of course, we pick our
research areas to have impact.
But the Nobel Prize is something
which is so extraordinary,
we are not working for that.
This is sort of something which,
yeah, for just a few of us
may come as icing on the cake.
But we get our excitement
and our satisfaction
by doing good physics.
AUDIENCE: I have two questions.
One is that you made this
discovery of this new kind
of matter in 1995.
Was there something that
happened between '95 and now,
or were you awarded
this recognition
from what happened in 1995?
KETTERLE: I think the
breakthrough was in '95.
It was a new form of matter.
But its impact could not
be predicted at that point.
And what has happened
in the last six years
is that numerous research
groups and my own research group
have exploited this
new form of matter,
and have shown that it has many
special properties, that it
can be used for many
fundamental studies in physics.
And people have also
taken first steps
to build matter wave sensors,
new sensors with that.
So the full impact, the
breadth of this discovery,
it took a few years for
that to become visible.
AUDIENCE: When you talk
about nanotechnology and some
of the applications, could you
give us a more solid example
of what you think in the
future will be possible,
something that maybe would
be used by a consumer?
I'm not really sure, but
or in the medical field,
or is there something like that?
KETTERLE: I think every
specific prediction
will be proven false.
And--
[LAUGHTER]
--that has actually
happened to the field.
People didn't predict what has
happened in the last few years.
But I don't want to
dodge the question,
but let me first be general.
We have atoms now with a
quality of laser light.
Atoms are the basic
building blocks of nature,
and we now have unprecedented
control over those building
blocks of nature.
This must be good for anything.
This must be good for many
things we can't even think of.
And what people
are discussing is
that you might now use
atoms and deposit them
on surfaces in fine patterns
and create some nano devices
of the future.
Other people think
that those atoms which
oscillate in lockstep
may eventually
be the clockwork
of novel computers.
But I want to stay
vague because these are
areas which are in exploration.
And the future will tell
what comes out of it.
But these are the
buzzwords, nanotechnology,
new forms of computation,
new atomic clocks.
And that's what
groups are working on.
KASTNER: There may be
questions from the telephone.
You could ask if there are
Just ask if [INAUDIBLE].
Ask if there are questions
from the telephone.
KETTERLE: Are there
questions from the telephone?
AUDIENCE: They're typing.
AUDIENCE: This is
Robert Lee [INAUDIBLE]
from the Los Angeles Times.
I wonder, sir, if you
would expand a bit
on the specific unusual
properties of the condensate
that you are today
being honored for.
I know you talked about
the moving in lockstep,
but I know that you've spent
considerable time examining
their broader properties.
And I wonder if you could
tell us a little bit about
that, please.
KETTERLE: Yes.
The Bose-Einstein
condensate has some cousins.
And those are superfluids
and superconductors.
You may be most familiar
with superconductors,
where electrical currents can
flow without any dissipation.
A superconducting
wire does not heat up
when carbon flows through that.
And the Bose-Einstein condensate
has similar properties
that atoms can be in
motion without friction,
without slowing down.
So those properties--
superconductivity,
superfluidity, they
carry the word "super"
because there's
something special to it.
And the Bose-Einstein condensate
is the most fundamental example
in this family of
super states of matter.
So it's coherence, absence
of friction, superfluidity.
These are more technical
words, but these
are the buzzwords
which I would associate
with very special properties.
AUDIENCE: This is [INAUDIBLE]
from the Washington Post.
Could you discuss your
atomic laser a little bit,
and tell me how you
were able to direct
the particles at a target?
KETTERLE: OK, the question
is about the atom laser,
how we direct particles
and how we created it.
When the Bose condensate
was discovered in '95,
people saw that it was an
ultra-cold cloud of atoms,
but people hadn't shown directly
that those atoms clearly
march in lockstep.
And this is the most
important property of a laser,
that it is one big wave.
In the case of light, it's
one big electromagnetic wave.
In the case of atoms, it's
one giant matter wave.
And when we realized
the atom laser,
we were able to show just that.
We could show that the
atoms in the Bose condensate
are really wave-like.
And secondly, we could create
the first rudimentary atom
laser by having atoms dripping
out of the condensate.
They were accelerated
by gravity and formed
the first coherent atomic
beams, again an analogy
with laser beams, which are
coherent beams of light.
Since then, other
groups have shown
how you can create more
directional atom lasers, most
notably the group of Bill
Phillips at Gaithersburg.
He was a Nobel laureate for
laser cooling four years ago.
AUDIENCE: I have a
few more questions.
What is your next step
with your research,
and what are you going
to do with the money?
[LAUGHTER]
KETTERLE: The next
step in the research
is to use the Bose condensate
to test fundamental physics,
to realize more
different and more subtle
new forms of matter.
We also have
experiments where we
try to put both
condensates on chips,
on micro fabricated surfaces.
So there is some hope
that we can create,
in the future, atom chips where,
you know, in ordinary chips,
the information is carried
by electrons moving in wires.
And now we want to
create atom chips
where atoms move close to a
surface and are guided around.
So we're talking about
a next major step,
and new perspectives
to the field.
I haven't thought what
I'm doing with the money.
I mean, I have a family, and
so there are many good uses.
But I have not spent any
second to think about it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
I have two questions.
First of all, where
were you when you
got the call winning the prize?
And second of all, you
touched on this a little,
but all of you are very
young and [INAUDIBLE]
after the research significance
has had a chance to sink in.
What do you think it is
about your research that
has made the physics
community immediately
recognize its importance?
KETTERLE: OK, the
first question is
where was I when I was
notified about the prize.
I was in the bed.
I was sleeping.
And it was 5:30 in the
morning, and the phone rang.
And it was Professor
[? Norbi, ?] the Secretary
of the Swedish Academy of
Sciences, who told me he has
some important news to tell me.
[LAUGHTER]
And then he informed me
that I am the co-recipient
of this year's Nobel Prize.
The other question was
that we are fairly young.
Yeah, it's probably
rather unusual
that research is
recognized just a few years
after the discovery.
But I think this reflects
that many colleagues worldwide
were immediately picking
up on those developments.
And I estimate that, since
'95, 2,000 scientific research
papers have been written on the
subject, which is really a lot.
So worldwide, the activities
of hundreds of scientists.
And I think this just showed
that this research had impact.
It has revolutionized
atomic physics.
So researchers vote
with their time.
And many of my colleagues have
voted that this is important,
and that this is promising
for further exploration
and developments.
MODERATOR: Are there
questions from the floor?
Are there questions from
the telephone group?
AUDIENCE: I guess i
just want to clarify
that one thing you're saying
about the atoms on the chips.
Does that mean
possibly, as I've read--
and I can't believe everything
I've read-- that you're talking
about the faster computers?
Is that what you?
KETTERLE: Faster computers.
Well, this research is
about ultra-cold atoms.
And ultra-cold means that
the atoms are very slow.
So we won't have an
advantage in speed
because atoms are moving sort
of like a lightning bolt.
But there's some hope to
use the coherence of atoms
for a new way of computation.
So quantum computers are
not necessarily faster
in terms of their clock
speed, they're just
much more efficient.
They do parallel processing.
It's a heavy
parallelism, which makes
them win big in that regard.
But if atom chips will lead
to this new class of quantum
computers remains to be seen.
This area of atom chips
is really in its infancy.
But it's a promising
direction to pursue.
AUDIENCE: Professor,
can you explain just
how cold [INAUDIBLE]?
KETTERLE: OK.
Bose-Einstein condensates are
characterized by temperatures
in the nanokelvin regime.
This is more than a
million times colder
than interstellar space.
So sometimes, I
mean, you can say
why is it not cold
enough to be 1,000 times
colder than interstellar space.
So well, there are phenomena
in physics and novel
properties of matter which
require to go even colder.
And so it was only when we
had developed techniques
to cool more than
a million times
lower than the temperature
of interstellar space
that we could observe
this new form of matter.
AUDIENCE: And were
the experiments
actually carried out at labs
here at MIT, or in both?
KETTERLE: They were
carried out in both labs.
There were independent
efforts at Boulder
using rubidium atoms, at
MIT using sodium atoms.
We were feverishly working
on those experiments
for several years.
And it was sort of remarkable
that, within a few months,
both groups succeeded.
It was in June that they had
the breakthrough in Boulder,
and in September when the
breakthrough at MIT happened.
MODERATOR: I want
to add that there
were a number of other
Nobel Prize winners
here in the room to celebrate.
And I wanted to invite them
to come up to join Wolfgang.
Sam Ting.
Professor Sam Ting.
AUDIENCE: Dr. Ketterle,
I wondered if you would--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Nobel Prize.
MODERATOR: Gary [? Friedman. ?]
And anyone else.
[LAUGHTER]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MODERATOR: The left
to right on this
is Ting, Ketterle,
Friedman, and Sharp.
AUDIENCE: But don't stop
smiling [INAUDIBLE]..
[LAUGHTER]
MODERATOR: And I also want
to bring in the students who
worked with Wolfgang
Ketterle on this project, who
are waiting in the wings.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MODERATOR: Dan is the head
of the [INAUDIBLE] lab
of electronics,
which has sponsored
much of Wolfgang's research.
Would you like to
say a few words?
Daniel Kleppner.
KLEPPNER: I'm not the
director of [? Areli. ?]
That's [? Irwin ?]
Shapiro, who is here.
And it's a wonderful
day for me personally,
and I think for my
colleagues, because we
have watched Wolfgang's
work since he came to MIT,
and admired so much how he
went about his work, his taste,
his goal, his enthusiasm.
He's a marvelous colleague, and
his accomplishment certainly
deserves the prize.
We're very pleased
that he has it
because there are many
accomplishments in science
which deserve the
prize but don't get it.
And in this case, we
have a success story
where the work really deserves
the prize and does get it.
I'm particularly happy
today because I've
had a long association
with the subject.
Tom Greytak and I many years
ago were among the first groups
to start searching for
Bose-Einstein condensation
in an atomic gas.
I knew nothing about it at all
before Tom explained to me what
Bose-Einstein condensation was.
And he explained it to me, and
it sounded kind of interesting.
So it was really
through his stimulation
that we started out in
this work many years ago.
And eventually, we did get it.
But we started very soon, and
we pursued the only method
open at the time, which
was with atomic hydrogen.
Later, when laser cooling
was invented and created,
it turned out that it works much
better with the alkali metal
atoms.
Nonetheless, we did get it.
And that was a great
satisfaction to us.
But I think what is even
more of a satisfaction
is that this field has
grown so remarkably
and had such an impact
on so many scientists.
And I take a
personal satisfaction
not only because of the
work that Tom Greytak
and I, the early
work that we did,
which is a prelude to this,
but because of the people
involved with it.
The Scientific American dubbed
me the grandfather of BEC.
Well, grandfathers can
be very happy people.
[LAUGHTER]
And I think I'm the grandfather
because Dave Pritchard was
my student, and he
brought in Wolfgang
and mentored his career.
So I'd say Dave Pritchard
then is the father
[INAUDIBLE] grandfather.
And Tom Greytak was
not a student of mine.
He's a brother.
So let me [INAUDIBLE].
MODERATOR: While we're
talking about family matters,
we have family that matters to
Wolfgang here, his two sons.
And I just want them to come
up, and he can introduce them.
[APPLAUSE]
KETTERLE: So well, I
have three children,
and they are all different.
My daughter told me this morning
she wanted to go to school.
[LAUGHTER]
Holger made already a memo.
My daughter, she's 12 years old.
Holger is nine years old.
And Holger, he
made a [INAUDIBLE]
to one of the reporters.
He said, the best
thing about my dad
winning the Nobel
Prize is I don't
have to go to school today.
[LAUGHTER]
And this is Jonas.
He's 15 years old, and he's
at Brookline High School.
But getting more
personal, I also
ask Dave Pritchard to stand
up and come next to me,
because it really speaks for
how the MIT system worked.
He hired me as a
postdoc in 1990.
I was in a different
field of physics,
and he was in the
cold atom field.
He hired me as a postdoc,
and I learned from him.
And after three years
of being a postdoc,
he said, so well, I've
taught you many things,
but now you can take my
lab and be on your own.
And two years
later, we discovered
Bose-Einstein condensation.
And it was sort of
executing a common agenda.
Some person on the phone
commented on my young age,
but there's also the wisdom of
an older person [INAUDIBLE]..
[APPLAUSE]
PRITCHARD: Well, you know,
when Wolfgang was my postdoc,
we came up with an idea that
was a modification of a trap
that I'd co-invented earlier.
And this idea
enabled us-- it was
called a dark spot
[INAUDIBLE],, a dark spot trap,
and it enabled us to hide
lots of the cold atoms
in the middle, in a dark spot
where the laser light didn't
shine, actually.
And the rest of the atoms were
pushed in by more laser light.
And the result of
this was that we
had gotten to a density of
atoms where it was apparent
that if we got really the
vaccum a little bit better,
we could begin to get much
colder by using the technique
that Harold Hess and
Dan Kleppner and Tom
Greytak had developed
called evaporative cooling.
That's very simple.
It's just the way
you cool your coffee.
You let the hottest
molecules escape,
and then the ones that
are left behind are cold.
Unfortunately, that doesn't
work in a very dilute gas.
You need to have
lots of collisions.
And so people have always
come up to me and said, Dave,
you know, what a sacrifice
you made by giving up
this experiment,
you know, just when
it was on the brink
of more progress.
And to me, it was a really
obvious and pleasurable,
and in fact this today makes it
even more pleasurable to have
done that, because what I got
for giving up one of my three
experiments-- and the other
two then went better because I
could work on them--
was a wonderful colleague.
I just can't explain
to you how much fun
it was to work with
Wolfgang then as a postdoc,
and now that we're doing
some new things with making
atom interferometers
on a chip and so forth.
And I mean, let's face
it, the experiment
went a heck of a lot better with
him running it than with me.
[LAUGHTER]
And so I thought it
was an easy call,
and especially to get another
addition to the atomic physics
group here.
It's been worth it.
And we're just so
happy he stayed.
[APPLAUSE]
MODERATOR: We also
do teaching at MIT,
and the cutting edge this
represents is part of that.
I want to introduce Marc
Kastner, the department
head of physics, who's
going to talk a little bit
about Wolfgang's teaching.
KASTNER: Wolfgang is one of
our most dedicated, passionate
teachers.
He's a superb educator
of graduate students.
We're going to bring his
students up in a minute.
He's a superb classroom teacher
at the undergraduate level.
This summer, he even took
a high school student
into his lab to excite
him about research.
I think he's the perfect example
of what a faculty member ought
to be at a research
university, someone who
does cutting-edge
research and brings
the excitement of that
research to the students.
And so just on behalf
of the department,
I want to thank you for
everything you do, Wolfgang.
[APPLAUSE]
KETTERLE: But I think
it's really time
that all the people who
currently work with me just
come up and join
this moment with me.
[APPLAUSE]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MODERATOR: [INAUDIBLE]
Nobel scientist.
KETTERLE: I could introduce
everybody individually and tout
his accomplishments, but
this is a fantastic team.
And accomplishment
in science really
require to work with a team.
I mean, the people
who stand behind
me also speak for this
explosive growth in the field.
When the research
was initiated, it
was just myself and
two graduate student,
or sorry, three
graduate students.
And then the team was growing.
Right now, we have a major
effort in different laps
just to explore all
those new possibilities.
But I really want to give
a big hand to this team.
They are really carrying
on this exciting research.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
I was just asked I
should give the names.
There's Todd [? Gustavson, ?]
[INAUDIBLE],, [INAUDIBLE],,
[INAUDIBLE],, Dave
[? Kipinski, ?] [INAUDIBLE]
[? Campbell, ?] [INAUDIBLE]
[? Chin, ?] [? Sharmila ?]
[INAUDIBLE],, [? Michael ?]
[? Boyd, ?] [INAUDIBLE],,
[? Johnny ?] [? Bogles, ?]
Jake Harris--
sorry-- that's when you
go to bed at two o'clock
and you are woken up.
[LAUGHTER]
At 6 o'clock, there's
[? Dominic ?] [INAUDIBLE],,
there's [INAUDIBLE],,
[INAUDIBLE] [? Gupta, ?]
and [? Yong ?] [INAUDIBLE],,
and [? Eric ?]
[? Street. ?] Sorry,
[? Dominic. ?] It's a
blackout which just happens.
[APPLAUSE]
MODERATOR: Are there are any
other questions from the press,
either on the phone or here?
AUDIENCE: I have one question
if we have [INAUDIBLE]..
I wonder, sir, if,
on the occasion
of the centennial
Nobel Prize, you
might reflect for us on the
relationship between the Nobel
Prize and the pursuit of
excellence in science.
KETTERLE: So well,
I mean the question
is about the centennial
of the Nobel Prize.
I think it's so special
to win the Nobel Prize,
nothing can top it.
So the fact that it's the 100th
anniversary, it makes it--
does it make it
even more special?
I think it's so special
that nothing can top it.
But I think 100 years
is a long tradition.
And I think for all
of those 100 years,
the Nobel Prize has really
distinguished great science.
And it shows that science
is exciting, and has not
lost any of its excitement
in the past 100 years.